to paul blue demon
[Applause]
cody splits a couple of defenders in the
layup balls
nice behind the back pass there by
little melo lamella
oh the pass at the bottom of the
backboard it stays with the hornets
and lamelo crawls it through attack
right there trying to get it to him the
free-throw line and he'd go the other
way and knock down another three
gordon hayward back over to lamello deep
three
all right first three ball for lavello
ball
here comes miles lamello made one a
moment ago
back to back threes for the rookie
didn't catch it clean
continues to stay aggressive right there
readjust
make sure he's got it
[Music]
lamelo hanks leaves it for cody
because he picked the ball up and held
it with one hand
hope he's okay and the hornets steal it
back
pj just has to get off the floor miles a
dunk
and we get a stoppage to see what's
going on with pj here's the 19 year old
lamello
leaves it for cody beautiful dime
over the foul trying to guard
autobiography it's spinning right there
project just lost cody that left-handed
pass here by lamelo
just don't know where it's going to come
from right over the head of